[Music]
guys i have this really ridiculously
stupid dumb criminal story
right in front of me [ __ ] yeah i love
dumb criminals let's [ __ ] with this guy
yeah right what used to be our intro for
the dumb criminals
way back in the day i forgot stupid ass
[ __ ] criminal news
something like that and stupid criminal
news
no wasn't it no is it like bad karma or
like not good good karma news
instant car my news oh noodles maybe one
of those instant noodles
sorry i don't okay anyway so this story
here it takes place in florida
florida and this is of course this 27
year old
man named herbert he walked into a gas
station
he walked into a gas station around 2am
and while he was there
and when the the cash the clerk cashier
guy was distracted
he reached over the counter and stole 13
different scratch-off lottery tickets
and then he left without paying for
those tickets but did he win it was
worth around 102
okay then a few hours later
he came back into the very same store to
try to get the 30 prize that he won
after scratching one of those tickets
obviously the employee called the police
and he got arrested
what a [ __ ] and dealing in stolen
property and
he's now being held on twelve thousand
dollars at least changed his clothes
i don't know but this is herbert he came
back in his robber outfit still
yeah remember me the guy with the ski
mask yeah i'm here to cash this out
thirty dollar prize that's the reason
why you want when you
get a like say you buy from this one um
say you go to seminar or liquor store
and then you buy a scratch off
right is it the company that has that
same place
the company that you bought the that
made the scratch out that pays you or is
it look at
the liquors because i know they give you
the cash immediately but then do they
hold that and be like oh you owe me
thirty dollars not because
yeah i think they pay so i think like
7-eleven pays you and then i think
7-eleven has to
uh report it to the lottery company or
whatever so you go to any liquor store
that sells those and be like
so he was just dumb and went to the same
one when you get like those
million billion dollar rewards
they get a cut too the story gets a cut
oh
for selling the winning ticket oh for
selling it not for like cashing it so if
you can't cash it out you don't have
that kind of money like if you buy let's
say i go to
casey 711 and i buy a winning ticket and
then i go to a bart's
gas station to collect my money [ __ ] you
why don't you come back over here
no he you get the money oh okay cool
like if it's a lottery ticket you don't
even have to go back
yeah just you just want so you know if
it's not a large ticket it's a scratcher
do i have to take it back
what he was saying go over there it
doesn't matter who cashes you out
because they're going to get the money
from yeah
i could take a winning scratcher to
another yes participating
yeah okay now i know and then they get
paid this guy's an idiot then yeah that
guy did not know
i gotta do his ass they get paid back
yeah that's funny yeah yeah yeah i'm
guessing
yeah i was reading a two this guy only
scratched one ticket too before
taking that one ticket of 30 dollar
reward to
well no the way they worded it says when
one ticket offered a 30
prize that's when he went they say he
went back to
so it could have been another one i
don't know but i guess one did it go
back at like
2 15 a.m like did he grab a glass i was
like yes
have you guys ever no they said they
said a couple hours have you guys done a
lotto pool before
yes do you remember when we did it yeah
we did so i forgot how much we put 11
oh i don't remember how much we put him
but we won like 11 yeah but
all of us put in madness it was like a
grand or two
was it that much yeah it was a lot of us
we all put i think it was like 10 people
and we all put in like 100 bucks a year
yeah so all of us were in the pool
right and i think all of us started to
already
assume we were going to win yeah and we
started thinking of a shopping list of
what we're going to get every day that's
pretty fun fun i always uh i enter a
raffle and i'm like
damn dude i'm about to drive this
[ __ ] nice as poor [ __ ] like
that these guys are broke and like yeah
obviously
that's the good good mentality to have
just act like you already have it or
like
think that you already won the law of
attraction secret yeah yeah but what
ended up happening was we lost
i think because i wasn't a believer oh
you did it you you ruined it for us
probably because i never think i'm gonna
win things i'm always like i'm not gonna
win this
it's like the people i only think is the
pew they're like oh i'm not gonna win
it's the people that just like
i completely forgot i bought that ticket
and like weeks were like nobody's coming
with the thing i was like
i just checked my purse i found this
crap i thought it was a receipt of about
throughout and it was like the winning
ticket and you're like i hate when
people say well why do people even buy a
lotto ticket and then put it in their
purse without even checking or
scratching forgetful
i think i guess like karma doesn't
reward those that are thirsty
yeah you gotta almost like you don't
care and then you win so we should
we should pull motion pool and all go i
don't care huh casey because yeah i
don't care
[ __ ] that because even when you say i'm
not going to win that is caring i don't
care
like even i remember i cared a lot and i
got a thousand dollars at the roulette
table
but maybe i would have got more if i
didn't care so much yeah you could have
been a billionaire right now it's true
like
when we play crap it's like when you
first walk up to the table you don't
really care because you're not
as invested in that session yet right
yeah but then that's when you win big
yeah but then when you win big you care
more and more that's when you lose
everything like this week we didn't we
[ __ ] gave up on krypto
and it went crazy after we were like
crypto's over i was playing roulette
right and
um i had all these like numbers beds
ready to go
the ball was spinning and you know how
like right when they're done the dealer
goes like no more bets right
so right before they did that this guy
came up he walked up
he put a 100 chip on 35 black guess
where it lands
30 45 [ __ ] black right wow god how
much is that right yeah what's the
payment
3500 500 bucks yeah well i don't know if
it was 35 but 100 bucks
i don't know if that was an actual
number right damn it was it was but it
was on the number it was 3 500
it's it's times 35 so it's time 35 or it
should be like times 10.
now it's 35 to 1 because on a roulette
table with however many numbers there
are if it lands on your number
that's the odds so they pay you by the
odds we're going to vegas together
yeah so that's probably where i got the
35 number but
um so he got paid out that and no sweat
right like a cool [ __ ] we're
like how did you know and he goes
sometimes you just know
and then he took the money he left and
we're like damn now that guy
that's what you do you gotta take the
money and leave yeah and then we're like
talking like that's how you gamble man
and then later we come you see him walk
him to the employee room and like
there's like a machine that like
does that to everyone and now everyone's
like putting money on the table like
crazy
later we see him we come back and his
shirt is half undone and he's betting
and betting and betting
and he loses everything and more
so i'm like okay that's the reason why
he could put a hundred dollar
on one number because he's probably done
that a million [ __ ] times
so that one time we see that magic we
think that he's a gambling master
but in reality it's because he's lost a
hundred thousand more
because he probably went from one two
three four five six all holidays
too thirsty he cared too much that's
probably what it is
yeah but because i saw you do that too
like i witnessed that
with you going into it and i lost a
roulette table
and you know i think i think you oh i
think i remember you winning because i
was like what the [ __ ] wedding red or
black
yeah i think it was a color like that i
love doing that with roulette by the way
blending
betting red i always like walk by even
if i'm not in a gambling mood
and i walk by and i see like on the
little digital screen it's like the last
six numbers were like red
yeah i'm like oh yeah 50 bucks back and
it's still red again yeah
like damn it it's like [ __ ] 100
when you got your money back you're like
i'm scared bye
always that's what i like about roulette
it's the most brainless
less strategic one but it's the most
exciting there's hella strategy in
roulette
what's the strategy i'd say that i'm
serious yeah but
that's your strategy like seeing the six
in a row reds
that's one strategy but for example like
okay let me see if i can explain this
right mathematics
there's more strategy than blackjack
it's like there's like 30 technically
there's like 36 numbers on sale because
of like the double zero green right yeah
so when you have 36
right you divide that into a pie because
it's a circle right most people usually
go bet the table
yeah they bet it on like uh and it
splits the thirds right like one two
three four five seven eight nine ten all
the way 35
yeah yeah yeah but the thing is the
roulette circle it doesn't go in
numerical order once again
so if once you understand the numbers
you could cover all four
exactly so instead what you do is is you
don't bet like you're just random nuts
you bet like a third of the pie
so that your chances of landing on your
number aren't so much higher
rather it's landing in your quadrant or
your section yeah
so if it lands on your section and you
bet a third right you're getting 35 to
one so you can if you win one time
because it lands your pie
you can technically lose three more
before you lose out your money yeah but
but the payout is worked out to where
it's
highly in the casino's favor man it's
just funner to think that there's no
strategy
just right there all right we'll finish
honestly roulette
is let me throw money into the sky and
hope more come down
see it's more fun thinking of it like
that well it's because that's all
gambling there
it is the only two mathematical
advantages that you have
is if you're counting cards in a [ __ ]
blackjack table
or you're playing poker and you can out
beat somebody yeah
other than that everything else is
pretty [ __ ] up
odds wise okay how many times you guys
gone to vegas and gamble right
every time how long does it really take
to play and like learn poker decently
and how often you actually go it takes a
long like ten years and then you're up
against people that can [ __ ] you
up no but i'm saying it's like if you
want to actually learn you could learn
but nobody
takes the time to learn poker yeah you
just go to gamble blindly just for the
fun of it you know
yeah that's what's fun that's what i do
yeah that's the fun part of it
yeah well that's what they make money
off of them fun party is
winning yeah that's the fun part the
funnest part is when you actually train
in poker and you get good after five
years and then someone beats the [ __ ]
out even though
it's my first time [ __ ] you then
oh the beginner's luck yeah sometimes
beginners like they kill you
dude i remember the very first time i
ever played with you guys it was i had
some like
some house party or something and then i
ended up like winning a decent stack and
i was just like i don't even know what
i'm
doing and you guys are all like
beginners look no there's times where
people they're like they don't even know
how to play the cards or like i see
people's moves and afterwards i'm like
okay that's what they have and then i
look at their cards and it's like
cars that would have thrown away a long
time ago and i'm like they catch the
river or something
like this that's like craps to me though
that's like even more like beginners
luck right somebody comes in and just
throws nice this is so much [ __ ] fun
mm-hmm
the thing about crafts though is like
that group mentality yeah we all
had something yeah it's like that's so
fun why can't people see like the owners
of these liquor stores
just be like [ __ ] i'm gonna scratch
all of these and hopefully one's like a
hundred thousand dollars the owner of
the liquor store yeah that was like the
employee
because then it's kind of like i'm
assuming because they get a [ __ ] ton of
those
well they're not working you have to pay
for them like they have to pay for each
one
yeah they have to pay for it say like
okay see there's a thousand uh
rolls right now one's gonna be like a
hundred thousand well that's like the
liquor store
like i'm gonna drink all my drinks i'm
like
you can't get high off your own supply
yeah what it's like but you're gonna
say he has a thousand rolls right and
he's like [ __ ] it i'm just gonna scratch
all these and hopefully i come update
right
and then imagine he does but it's it's
bad for
business because the way that gambling
works is it's not in your favor
what's because they out of 1000 people
only buy one right and it's like you're
getting all this money from them
but it's like imagine you just take all
that no no no
so okay the way that it works right it's
a losing business
for you to do that over over time
so let's say all you got to do is get
lucky once because you're not the casino
you're if you're scratching all the
tickets right if you're 7-11 and you
work there
you're basically just giving all your
profits away
for years and years until you actually
hit so like let's say out of 10 000
there are some winnings right
but then it's made to bleed you out over
time
yes you might be able to hit but the
odds are so
crazy that you probably won't hit yeah
wouldn't that be illegal too for the
liquor store i mean there's got to be
some
legality to it because it sounds like
that mcdonald's
uh thing that happened with the monopoly
game where like the mcdonald's workers
were playing the monopoly game
themselves
they had higher odds because they had
access to all the they're well they also
cheated too
kinds of yeah but you can't like win the
lottery if you someone you know works
for the lottery
yeah they have that liquor store not the
lottery
yeah yeah the mcdonald's one goes a
little bit deeper because
they knew were the winning things yeah
he actually had the winning stuff
yeah yeah he was like giving it to
family and friends
the actual like winning piece for the
monopoly thing
you know what people started doing on
[Music]
ebay
[Music]
so